in this capsule we will see the concept
of unification the unification is going to be
the second tool that will need to
to prove by resolution then
the unification
so what are we going to try to do with
unification is from a pair
of alphard literals and alpha 2 we're going
try to find a substitution
maybe time yes that will allow
to unify half hour and alpha 2
that is to say, is such that if I apply
alpha 1 substitution and I have the
same alpha substitution 2 I'm going
get exactly the same literal
konqueror of it's heroes who are the
same who are equal so see example
if I had the literal pf2 xyz and country
is capitalized and I had the substitution
y by f 2 x and z by a
and well this substitution the head to
would unify but literals here
actually I'm here if I apply
teta a pdf of exide so I have to
replace z with z and replaced here by
a change not since exit no
involved in my substitution and if
I'm applying teta ap from there
I have to change seems blix so there is
modified and then substituted by f 2 x and
I actually get that f
b2f of x1 here and pdf dx has here so i have
managed to unify but 2 0 with my
substitution has sometimes
it's impossible to unify
literals in an example here pdf 2 x ap2
y f2 w are not united reliable because
I will not be able to make a solution that
will allow me to have to and f2 w ego
after the substitution I can not between
others substitute for the expression
term f2 w I can only change
variables by internal
in fact not interested in finding
the unifier who is the one who is the
more general so a more cagole
general or the acronym of the pg it's going to be
a unifying head that is such that
for any other sigma unifier he goes
exist exit sorry there will exist a
substitution range such as if I
dial kid with your tab and I'm going
get this other cinema substitution
will see a perfect example sometimes the
substitution you shut up we saw this
in fact the pg and so what we show
here no it's not a demonstration that
it's a pj but just that it's beautiful
and a victory is what we have
done now now we have another
substitution
sigma who will match it will make legal requirement
and that's really a unifying
but it's not great for both
same top2 fdf z p2 so there is
actually if I apply six dead ap
of f2 xyz
am I going to get that is xv
is replaced by a
exit will be replaced by rogers pdf 2 to
1 then if I go back I forgive I
remember that the sigma substitution to
p2y12 will be replaced by kiev must
so I will once again gave country
of f2 has therefore actually applied
this substitution but the idea
red gets exactly the same thing
it allows me a girl on the other hand
it's not an ivg
but my other substitution also and
pg
so actually if I define range
by committing x equal to messi I combine
I compose
tda with sygma it will give me this here
so I let you do the exercise the
of derivatives this composition the head
with gama if I use it as my head
right here
on the other hand for the cinema that I have
defined here it's impossible for me to
find a kid who will allow me to
find some time while sometimes
I had managed to define a kid who
do I actually get a
substitution which is equal to sygma so
for this reason the teta in this
example ipg theater but simone is not
a draw in fact my price that has
held pg it would have to demonstrate that
some realities sigma as soon as
it's a unifying good it exists
always a kid
actually we do not offer that kind of
problem is what are we going to see if a
algorithm that will allow us to
find a unifier that is the most
general in the sentry box that we will see
goes to the needs of the notion of a
set of disagreement a set of
disagreements in two liberals it's going to be
the pair of the first term from
the left that differ between the two
lateral
so we see two examples if we take
still the same two top-10 of xyz
ears of y to the whole of disagreement in
this case it's the set of f2 x and
y actually part of the left the
are not the first term f2 x here and
Greek
they are different so that's my
whole disagreement because if
I had as literals pdf of exile
despite the peaks to when it's in
starting from the left gf2 x which is the
same thing as fdx here so it's not
my set of second-term disagreement
z and they are different so the world
set of disagreement becomes the whole
aid and to
so here is the pseudo code to find
the most general unifier first
step what we do is we
initialize is our substitution
we're going back we'll start with
identity substitution so it's so
the forgiveness man then that's what we
is that we check if our
current substitution so here we did not
who will dispute
so if it's mac and cinema what is it
our our current substitution allows
to unify the liberals in s
if so I can return my
substitution it turns out it lies
that it's going to be a super g for my
together liberals
on the other hand if it is not the case I must
calculate persimmons and the set of
disagreement to militate rohou she
I applied my current substitution
afterwards I looked at what
exists a variable pair term so mtb
open a variable that belongs to
my set of disagreement who is who
does not appear in the term so you are
I want a variable part open term
do not appear in your v belongs my
set of disagreement and especially the
substitution v equality allows to unify
the elements in my set of
disagreement so that allows me to settle
my problem that there are some of
terms of a military or who are not
equal if I succeed in finding this
so bead to find this substitution
washes equality well i'm going
incorporate it into substitution
current if my body to the component
with the substitution v equality and that that
gave me my new substitution for
my integration into the sigma as more
healthy and it's going to be the substitution that
I will consider alliterations
next
so I'm going back to step 2 where I
am going to check is what my new
substitution makes it possible to unify the
interros in s if yes I return them
otherwise I convinced the years his desire to
okay and I do are located up
what I managed to unify all
fully unify the eroding elite where
I did not manage to make a
indication so I have not managed to
find a substitution that will me
allow to unify the elements my
set of disagreement and in this case there
it means that ace europe unified so
instead I will return
something that lets you know there
so maybe a ball to fake you
go lets know that it's
impossible one line is the potting soil
in ace then we will do two examples
to help understand
how does the algorithm function test then
at the very beginning i start with
empty unification one would be an example
montmédy the soil cp2 excipe of xy and
p2y12 could because if xyz and u are
variables
oprah iteration i start with
empty unification and I'm checking is this
that it allows to unify but May 2 of
it and break ex fds ex y and p2 yz
and so if I apply unification the
substitution bilge gets exactly the
even literal is more than deserved but
of the uterus are not equal that's because
that it does not allow me to unify them so
the next step is to find
the set of disagreements d1 who
corresponds to my two liberals to whom
I applied my substitution which
substitution quickly so it's the soil
originals and in this case the whole
disagreements correspond to both
first terms of melita x and y
so my chord set if
the set of xy the game I'm trying to
find a substitution that goes to me
allow to unify the elements in
my set of disagreement
because if it's possible to do a
substitute to experts y so I build
an ex equal substitution y is I'm going
update my simoën by the
component with excess galls y since
otherwise they together empty the composition
indulge x equal is there so that's my
update to my candidate for my
most general indicator operations
following so sigma 2 and galas x there
ya all is that these guys there
does that mean it may be 0.6
I apply sigma 2 ap 2 except xy
I get p2y12 y / y the judge loaded x by
there
like Saturday in the substitution if I
called it cap and y or z pu if
I apply sigma 2 p2 are sure
since mode 2 sign does not change there by
anything i still get p2y12
is it's not equal to p2y12 yy
so I calculate my set of
disagreement of the two
because here too we have the same thing
so we go to the second term f2 y is
equal to z
so my whole disagreement is
the set and this is the set f2 y and z
I was watching what exists
a substitution that allows me to unify
my elements from my set of
disagree yes I could change there by
zdf forgiveness of y
it would allow me to have f2 y and z
substitute by greeks so y so I
can update my substitution
ciném'aude hours the component with my
new substitution pardon z is equal
f2 is there if I do that I get and that
it is equal to y and z is equal to f2 y
third iteration I went with
sygma 3 which is these guys yz equals f
is what it means but 2 0 sigma
three stakes ap fdf xy
do not talk about x 2 xy it gives
p2y12 yy
if I then apply my substitution
cinema 3 ap of said there men's sam
p2 yfz450r is substituted by f2i there is
have not changed but I have not yet
equality between the two is my whole
disagreement in this case it's not at
level of the first term is not at
level of the second land leveled
third time
we are there now I was watching what
it's possible to make a substitution
which will allow me to unify my
elements in my set of disagreement
yes I could take the variable y there
was able to kill by the variable y is dense
that if we update cinéma3 by my
new solution has had
and if you calculate the substitution this
that you're going to get it's the solution
x also had damage came there
also had his new week so
substitution after my third
iteration
cinema4 fourth iteration I watch
does my substitution allow me
to unify but the potting soil if I apply
sigma that to type 2 x 2 xy I get
country of hu
f2 had enough of that if i apply
sigma than typing greek judge
once again gets p2 uef from eu
so actually synhorcat is a
indicator for my two side and he
will find my guarantee pace that
it's also the upg for for a world
together is so that's what I'm going
return like a cage and the algorithm
will stop
let's keep second example with both
lateral pdf yx ep 2 xy
I start again the first
iteration with empty substitution and
I looked at what it unifies but the
potting of course that leaves a girl
not since they are different my
set of disagreement your hebdo is there
x now is what exists a
solution that unifies
d1 breeders
oh yes I could charge experts fbi y
so is I dial cigna 1 with my
new substitution which gives me
since it's christmas together empty etc
segal f2 y
second iteration I was watching what
six modules unify but predicts
than yx 2 x usb 2 xy sorry if I the
pay that a sigma 2 api of f2 yx chopin
pdf of y
f2i greek if i called it capped 2 xy
i get p2f 2 yy are they there
equals no here actually men
are equal but here I have my set of
disagreement f2 is there you put in ace
which exists a substitution that me
Unify the elements of six years
aboard a meter d 2 1 no since I
can not be affected y af of the greek it's
what should I do if I wanted
that these two things here are equal
however, it is an assumption that
can aline because the variable to
left appears in the right term
and that's something that is
illegal we can not do that in our
substitution is for good
valid finish of a substitution and to
because of that so we are not able to
do the unification of the elements in
all the disagreements and so we
returns must we return a signal that
says we can not do it
pg because actually our coastlines are
not united reliable